how bad of an idea it would be to gift
my 18-year-old son my childhood home
tell me about your I couldn't ask for
any better kid through school and stuff
like that he he got him a job uh working
at a same Factory where my wife works at
so you led the question how bad of an
idea is it and I'm not trying to read
too much into that but me think some
reason that makes think it's a bad idea
why do you think it's a bad idea yeah
what's going on well I mean just just
handing handing an
18-year-old kid a a house yeah I'd give
it to him really yeah but I'm going to
put some terms on it here's my terms
okay I want to hear this okay I want him
to have a plan for his life right and
for the renovation of the property
that's his sign that he and and the
third thing is he promises never to
borrow any money